hi Jan welcome back to Croatia you were
here in 2021 what kind of memories do
you have from that times
um yeah I think it was mostly good
memories I mean my tournament was
so so I finished a short fourth I think
for fifth Viviana
memories as well but um I mean in that
very tournament I want two games I mean
beats games against Kasparov which was
of course A very huge thing for me back
then and yeah I mean you know I played
good games about games but in general I
was very like happy
with my performance here in the group so
yeah I'm looking forward you know
repeating it yeah I mean but but gaining
better uh you know I'm crazy
yeah that's important yes and actually
uh now that the last time I saw you was
in Poland and this dramatic last round
you know when you played against Magnus
and like I was just wondering how did
you feel after that event and let's see
what happened after did you still
analyze this game or you just decided to
forget about it and just enjoy the
second place like what were your
feelings right after that grandchester
yeah I was quite unhappy to be honest
back then because usually you know when
you are a professional chess player that
is usually about negative like feedback
because when you win you win because
you're yourself and when you lose and
especially when you feel you could you
know do better
and or make some you know unforceable
errors then
um yeah it can get very negative and in
my case it was like purely I mean second
place didn't make me happy dog because I
was like leading in most of the
tournaments but
um yeah but subjectively saying I guess
uh it was quite good performance by by
me and I'm looking to repeat it yeah
yeah I mean just really played really
well in Rapid and Blitz in Poland and
everybody noticed that you play normally
really good in uh in these events in
Poland but grantchester you know it's
it's happening in different places do
you think it kind of it has some impact
on chess players if you play in
different countries I mean does it
matter that much where you play or it's
not that's important
yeah I would say it's not so important
yeah but somehow it's rude and important
thing also I
did play very well in two last years so
yeah perhaps there is something you need
I'm not quite sure unfortunately you
know there are not so many great
tournaments in Poland
but but still I mean there are you know
coming new and new strong ones
and I guess you know transport is like
in each place like looks like the same
so I guess it's
um
in the end of the day doesn't really
matter yeah
um and those like speaking about Poland
do you feel that chess is like booming
right now in Poland and um like what's
happening right now do you feel the
difference last years before probably
after covet yeah I think a couple of
years ago he was like hi uh when in
pandemia times when there was also
Queen's Gambit series and right now I
think I mean I feel rather I kind of
stopped but um but still of course you
know
people like following trust and playing
chess so
you know I'm mostly focused on my own
career and don't really follow what's
going on let's say but um yeah but I
mean just I guess just has never been as
popular yeah yeah for sure it was always
popular and actually it's really hard
not to focus only on your games and not
on the audience because I remember they
were even saying something in Polish
language
like this before the last round I mean
it was really impressive uh yes and like
speaking about your career what are your
big goals what goals do you have for
this year
um well I have two guns
um
first and foremost I guess it's uh to
play well in the World Cup I don't
really see myself winning it again but
you never know I mean two years ago I
was actually feeling terribly in Sochi
but somehow one in the end so and you
never know and secondly to do I'm great
here I mean going to store series
overall and
yeah I think these two things are like
kind of the most important yeah that's
great and all the best of luck for you
in achieving all those goals thank you
[Music]